cette fontaine cool ici au moins depuis
15 ans sans interruption
oui
alors voilà en effet ouvert le réservoir
de la fontaine saint jacques
donc tout à fait en pierre l'intérieur
et qui est exactement contemporain de la
fontaine elle même
[Musique]
m
voilà nous sommes donc blond l'intérieur
du gouffre dans la partie médiane
on a donc sur ma gauche la partie
réservoir captation et sur ma droite la
partie à glück c'est à dire le lac 2 qui
mène aux fontaines depuis les époques
les plus anciennes
on a capté un certain nombre de sources
dans le coteau de beauce en partie avec
la nappe phréatique
on a mis tout ça dans un réservoir au
16ème siècle en 411 le conseil municipal
le blue avec d'être là puis louis xii a
décidé de faire un système centralisé
beaucoup plus normal et c'est à ce
moment là qu'on a recreusé part de ce
réservoir
on la construit ce petit bâtiment pour
le protéger de tous les impuretés de
tous les détenus ce qui pouvait tomber
dedans
auto
pour ce qui est du gouffre il n'a pas à
repérer de source véritable c'est à dire
un lieu où l'eau pourrait sortir avec un
débit régulier et en abondance ça dans
le gouffre ça n'existe pas
en revanche on a de l'eau qui sainte qui
ruisselle continuellement donc ce n'est
pas à proprement parler une source mais
c'est quand même une alimentation
constante
est-ce que c'est l'eau de la nappe
phréatique est ce que c'est désormais
seulement c'est pas exactement en tout
cas il ya plusieurs captages et le beauf
que joue une sorte de rôle de château
d'eau me fontaine pour une ligne très
moyenne comme bouygues à plus de 10000
habitants à l'époque c'est un luxe est
assez peu de villes en france sauf
d'evento évidemment avec qui peuvent
bénéficier d'autant de fontaines à une
ville comme tout ce qui est quand même
beaucoup plus grande que blois à
l'époque n'a qu'une seule fontaine la
fontaine de beaune qui existent encore
[Musique]